las sirenas se escucharon en la noche
mientras algunos vehículos y viviendas
estaban envueltos en llamas decenas de
personas murieron con la explosión de un
camión cisterna de combustible en la
segunda ciudad más grande de haití a
última hora del lunes las autoridades
temen que el número de víctimas aumente
también dicen que los hospitales locales
están desbordados y que debido a la
carbonización de los cuerpos es difícil
identificar a las víctimas
naturalmente se perdieron muchas vidas
humanas pero hasta ahora no podemos dar
un número
porque ha habido muertos dentro de las
casas que aún no hemos identificado
la explosión también dañó las fachadas
de las casas los comercios y calcinó
motos y vehículos el primer ministro
haitiano dijo que se desplegarán
hospitales de campaña en la zona para
ayudar a los afectados y declaró duelo
nacional se decretarán tres días de luto
nacional en todo el país en memoria de
las víctimas de esta tragedia que ha
sumido en el luto a toda la nación
haitiana los hospitales de campaña se
desplegarán rápidamente en cabo haitiano
para proporcionar la atención necesaria
a las víctimas de esta terrible
explosión la explosión es la última
tragedia que golpea la nación mientras
haití lucha contra la agobiante escasez
de combustible y la espiral de precios
de gasolina el país también se vio
sumido en una crisis política a mediados
de este año tras el asesinato del
presidente yo en el mois y un terremoto
de magnitud 7,2 en agosto mató más de
dos mil personas y destruyó más de diez
mil viviendas